yes sir oh we have someone that's going  to force this way here we go  this should be interesting  150 for poopy out your butt  uh um i'm not sure i understand what  that means kentucky you're gonna give  what you're gonna you want 150 dollars  to pool  you want to give us 150 to put poop up  your butt no no please please stumble  closer  what exactly did you mean and when did  in what order did you lose your job  family and children  let me just tell you something this is  you in 30 years right here right behind  you to the casino  taylor hicks you sit in the [ __ ] down  you had your time and it was 15 years  ago  he's just doing the macarena back to his  scene you know that there's 2 000 of us  here we will all remember this he will  not remember that yes 150 of a poopy in  my butt what does it even mean